hello everyone and welcome to the start
of the tata still chess tournament 2022.
uh it's the neil double versus shakhtar
mahmoud and we could choose pretty much
any game from this round except a few of
them and we would have a a great game to
cover but i decided to start with this
one as it's just uh you know it features
everything that i enjoy uh mostly uh but
we're gonna cover other games from round
one as well so uh without further ado
let's check it out daniel dubo with the
white pieces opens with d4 uh sorry
about that uh we have d5 by mamedyarov
uh and now c4 uh we have
c6 going for the slav defense knight to
f3 knight to f6 and now knight to c3 and
here e6 we have the semi-slop defense
and now usually you go either bishop to
g5 or e3 but here dubo prepared
something very special and he plays g3
which means that he is very comfortable
in giving up a pawn because as c6 has
already been played it means you can
capture on c4 and defend the pawn with
b5 uh without uh having to worry about
anything uh so d captures on c4
mamidyarov accepts this gift uh bishop
to g2 and now b5 just defending that c
for pawn and now knight the e5 with a
double attack on the c6 pawn so how can
you defend this well you don't really
want to defend this you can play some
like bishop b7 or bishop to d7 because
whatever you try not captures on b5 and
well you've just won a pawn and you you
have a better position uh so instead
madero just plays a6 now the b5 pawn is
nicely defended uh and now we have
castles now you could actually capture
on c6 but uh well dubo did not come here
to to grab pawns it would seem so here
dubo just castles and now bishop to b7
now the pawn is nicely defended uh and
what can you well look at this massive
pawn chain of course now duba will
undermine the pawn chain with b3
but b3 is also inviting black to create
a pass pawn already on move 10
because what happens if b4 knight moves
in c3 you already have a protected pass
pawn on c3 and that's exactly what mommy
daryl does so b4 knight the a for nc3 so
what did dubo gain from this uh other
than our attention uh what is this well
he's going for knight to c4 and then
he's going to have excellent control of
this b6 square
which will put a lot of pressure on
black's queen side and the center and
also he wants to play e4 e5 and then
control the d6 square so those are kind
of the ideas and he will further
undermine the spawn chain with a move
like a3 so here we have knight to c4 uh
and now a5 uh clearing the a6 square or
you can now play bishop to a6 you can
play knight to a6 so many ideas here uh
a3 challenging the b for pawn and now
bishop to a6 attacking the knight here
and now
you could try a lot of different things
but here
we have bishop to f4 a captures on b4
was a known move in the position but
bishop to f4 is a known move so now as
of move 13 we have a completely new game
uh and it's uh mamidarov to figure out
what to do here so yeah you could easily
uh make uh well a move that isn't so
great for example if you try bishop to
e7 you just want to castle let's say a
captures on b4 and we're going to
capture on c4 and after let's say b
captures on c for a captures now you can
play c5 and now look at this you have
beautiful control of the b6 square you
have very nice control over the d6
square
you're going to play queen to b3 you're
gonna bring the other rook to b1 and it
doesn't matter that black has two
connected past pawns white will uh have
no problem whatsoever playing this the
c6 pawn is a weakness black cannot
develop the knight so this is something
that dubo was was hoping to get but
momodaro plays the absolute best idea in
the position and that is bishop to b5 so
what can you do here now
uh so here if you uh just continue with
a captures on b4 we can capture a
capture on b4 and there is nothing to
worry about black is perfectly fine here
so duval continues with his plan he
pushes e4 now he's preparing e5 to grab
uh more control over the d6 square
bishop to e7 mahmoud needs the castle
his king is still in the center of the
board and now finally knight a to b6
going after the rook here so rook to a6
and now we have a4 attacking the bishop
here now the point is uh if for example
bishop captures knight captures uh mommy
are castles we have a normal game that
the game just continues uh duo will at
some point play e5 open up this diagonal
claim the d6 square probably for his
knight and well that's what it's going
for however the mamadirov says nope i
have something better i have rook
captures on b6 and now okay you can't
capture with the knight because th this
rook would be hanging so here we have a
captures on b5 first grabbing the bishop
rook captures on b5 so now it's a clear
pawn
and now rook to a2 uh uh now preparing
queen to a1 to put more pressure on the
a5 pawn uh
even though instead of rook to a2 you
could go for something like bishop
captures on b8 and try and win your pawn
back rook capture so now you're going to
capture rook captures on a5 but it's
still not all that much black will just
trade for example captures captures and
yes you've equalized in material but you
still have problems here black has a
pass pawn on c3 and you really have
nothing to show for it so instead doobo
keeps the tension he plays rook to a2
and mamidarov castles now to safety we
have queen to a1 uh and now by playing
queen to a1 uh dubo also offers the d
for pawn so uh well
you you have to accept this it's simply
too delicious upon and not to be
captured so queen captures on d4 and now
rook to d1 first uh gaining a tempo on
the queen before we capture on a5 so
queen back to a7 and now only now knight
captures an a5 with a target here uh
knight captures on c6 for example if
this knight moves or maybe we can
capture the knight play knight captures
on c6 so this is all uh potential uh you
know do do both has a lot of potential
in the position but he he currently is
not better but of course he knew that
because he willingly went into this and
now we have bishop to c5 just attacking
that f2 pawn he doesn't mind about
knight captures on c6 opening up a
discovery on the black queen uh so this
is what a dupe of plays knight captures
on c6 bishop captures on f2 with check
king to h1 and now queen to b6 uh now
what what do you do the problem is if
you play knight captures here of course
not we're not going to capture with the
rook and allow the bishop to capture it
we're just going to chase away the
bishop and only after the bishop moves
we're going to play rook captures on b8
and now it doesn't matter even if you
capture here we can even capture with
the g pawn because our position is just
so much better white has nothing to show
for it and we all we still have our past
pawn on c3 so instead bishop captures on
b8 was played we have queen captures on
c6 and now only now e5 so uh now we've
reached the position from the thumbnail
the queen is attacked the knight is
attacked the bishop is ready to go to d6
the uh completely uh controlled at the
center and uh what can mommy darf play
well a good moves here are knight to d5
and knight to e4 knights the d5 seems to
be a
more sturdy of a defense but uh for
example after bishop to d6 it's not easy
to find a move for black best for black
is bishop the c5 you have to give up the
exchange and after bishop captures we're
going to play bishop captures on f8 and
you continue with this position again
keeping your beautiful pawn on c3
however momodarov did not like this he
played knight to e4 and there are
now there are a lot of tactics in the
position but the problem is uh what do
you do now you can't really move the
knight and after the row comes to e2 how
how will you defend this knight if f5
we're just going to play e captures on
f6 alpha song so here bishop the d6
first attacking the rook and now mahmoud
needs to play uh uh well just just
perfectly if he if he wants to achieve
any advantage here so i'm gonna show you
two really fun lines one is bishop to c5
the one that we've already discussed uh
asking duo to capture the rook here but
of course the white will play rook to e2
because now we go after the knight first
and after f5 defending the knight we're
going to play e captures an f6 alpha
bishop captures on d6 and now rook
captures any uh e4 or
well preparing some very nasty
discoveries here now queen to c7 and of
course rook captures on e6 and it's a
very nice position for for both white
and black there is a move that is really
tricky for dubo to handle and that is
bishop to e3 a very very difficult move
to spot uh because not only do you open
up the f2 square for the knight but you
also cover the queening square so now c
to c1 could be could be very interesting
and the idea is that after bishop
captures an f8 we play c2 now we're
going to play rook to e1 and now king
captures an f8 just you know
cold-bloodedly uh rook captures in c2 we
offer the rook now queen captures on c2
and now queen to a8 with check king to
e7 and now after bishop captures and e4
is played uh well this is the position
but black still is uh is doing very much
okay here and uh
it's uh well it is just a very very
double-edged uh players are very very
low on time it's only moved 31 so they
still need to play uh nine more moves to
reach time control and obviously
momodaro did not like what he saw so
instead he decided to keep the exchange
he played rook to d8 but now uh he just
gives dub of everything here duval
played rook to e2 putting pressure on
this uh e for knight and now we have f5
defending the knight and also inviting e
captures an f6 alpha which do both
played
and now uh well now it's very
interesting because there there is a uh
well a hidden mate lurking here but it's
not really a mate for example if knight
captures on g3 with check bishop covers
the g1 square h captures here rook to h5
is checkmate so how did dubo miss this
uh the thing is uh he didn't because the
bishop on d6 also covers the g3 pawn so
if knight captures we can capture with
the bishop and now it's perfectly fine
for example rook to d5 and uh
there's really nothing to do here rook
to d5 is a tricky move uh because uh
well you never want to give up your your
bishop here because this bishop covers
the g1 square and if the black queen
claims this diagonal for herself white
will be in big trouble but we can play
some like rook captures on v5 rook
captures on d5 and real captures on f2
and it's perfectly fine this is
completely winning for white
uh so instead after e captures um on f6
of course you do not have this very nice
knight captures on g3 check so c2 was
played uh threatening the rook here and
now we have f7 with check uh inviting
the king to capture it you can go to f8
and of course if you go king to h8 then
well it's just dead lost we're going to
play bishop captures on e4 attack the
queen also ponte f8 is coming at at some
point so there's not all that much black
can do here so instead after f7 check we
have king captures on f7 now uh here we
have queen captures on d6 uh sorry after
uh we have rooked f1
uh and it was uh well actually in this
position that dubois and the mamidar
agreed to a draw as they are both
incredibly low on time i believe they
were uh below the the two minute mark
both of them and they still have to make
like 10 more moves to reach time control
and the position is just too too
explosive you know to to tamper with it
uh so it was just you know on move 30
they agreed to a draw which is okay
because the position is objectively a
draw but it's uh well it's only if
mamijarov plays the the absolute best
move and that is pawn to c1 uh promoting
uh his pawn to a queen which prevents
rook captures on f2 and of course you
can't play something like this rook
captures on f2 because then knight
captures on f2 comes with check the rook
cannot capture because it's pinned and
now we're going to see something like
king to g1 queen captures on a1 and
after bishop captures in c6 we're gonna
even see queen captures on f1 with check
king captures and now rook to f5 and
look at this position two rooks and the
knight against two bishops of course
this would be completely winning for
mamidyarov so the thing is after the
queen is brought into the game we're
going to have to play some like rook
captures on c1 queen captures on d6 now
bishop captures an e4 and now bishop to
d4 getting our bishop to safety
attacking the white queen queen to b1
attacking h7 and now g6 and this is
basically the position that we will get
on move 33 where the players would be
very very low on time but it seems that
neither of them wanted to play this
which is i know uh might be a little bit
disappointing for for most of you
because uh
double was uh well he was worse more
most of the game or or
or rather he was the worse uh if you ask
the engine uh but if you ask him he he
will probably say that he had a very
very comfortable disadvantage throughout
the game and then he equalized you know
so i'm pretty sure he would say
something like this and uh well it's
still a very rich game a lot of things
can happen and bishops are of opposite
colors the kings are completely you know
bare naked so we would see
we would definitely see some sort of an
attack here because it's very hard to
balance this out
but it was too much for them and after
rook to f1 they agreed to a draw
so that's game one of the tata steel uh
2022 hope you guys enjoyed it uh we're
gonna check out uh some other games as i
see you guys are suggesting quite a lot
of them already uh i would like to thank
patreon and andrew dinihan link mike
wagner and joseph henderson for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon uh continuing the coverage of
the tata still of course until it
finishes uh thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day